acabar con el vacío en las estadísticas
para cambiar la realidad el censo
brasileño incluye una pregunta que
abarca a los miembros de los llamados
quilombos por primera vez en sus 132
años de historia
aparecer en los números de la
composición demográfica del país es otro
paso hacia el reconocimiento de los
descendientes de las personas
esclavizadas que escaparon de los
trabajos forzosos para crear estas
comunidades aisladas y autosuficientes y
comprobado que la Navidad allí ya se
sabe para nosotros es verificar lo que
en realidad ya se sabe Cuántos somos
dónde vivimos Y qué producimos
hay una ceguera intencionada para que no
salgamos en las estadísticas ni en
ninguna encuesta
el proceso que busca romper con parte de
su invisibilización histórica se ha
tomado las calles de isla de mare
uno de los seis mil territorios
reconocidos como quilombos en Brasil
allí sus habitantes esperan que el
proceso deriven mejores servicios
sociales y en políticas públicas que los
incluyan pero su reivindicación no sólo
radica en el censo ante las elecciones
estatales y federales de octubre
paralelas a las presidenciales se
presentan un número récord de candidatos
afrodescendientes
un paso para revertir las estadísticas
actuales de los 513 legisladores
elegidos para la cámara baja del
congreso en 2018 menos de una cuarta
parte se identificaron como negros
de nada sirve querer derrocar a
bolsonaro y mantener a los diputados y
alcaldes que responden de la misma
manera y de nada sirve poner a un
presidente pensando que será el Salvador
de la patria si no cambia todo el
congreso
los comicios desde octubre parecen
marcar otro punto de inflexión para
encontrar una mayor representación de la
población afrodescendiente en Brasil una
que ha sido silenciada múltiples
momentos de su historia incluso después
de 1888 cuando se convirtió en el último
país en acabar con la esclavitud